[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF SHARKEY: Hey, everyone.
My name is Jeff Sharkey,
and I'm a software engineer
on the Android Framework Team.
And today, we're going to be
digging into files on Android
and all the various
places that Android
gives you to store those files.
So today, we'll dig
into you starting
by looking at some common
locations that Android offers.
The first broad category
is internal storage,
and this storage can be
classified as safe and secure,
because it's something
the Android OS protects.
It's part of the application
sandbox model that we offer.
You've probably encountered
some of these directories
before, like
Context.getFilesDir.
It's a great default
location to store things.
One that's slightly
different is getCacheDir.
We'll dig into that a
little bit later today,
but one thing to
note is that files
that you store in that
location, the disk space
is not counted against
your application.
And the reason for that is
that Android reserves the right
to go in there and
delete some of those
files if the user needs
that disk space elsewhere.
So it's a trade-off.
It's a two way street.
Another directory
getNoBackupfilesDir,
this can be useful if you have
things like cloud messaging
tokens that you want to
renew when your app migrates
between devices.
If the device goes through
a backup and restore phase,
those files that you
store in that directory,
they won't be carried
across the backup.
So it be useful for that.
Finally, getCodeCache directory.
This is a great
place to store things
like jitted code
or optimized code,
and the OS will do two things.
It will delete contents inside
of the directory under two
conditions-- either when
your application is updated
via Play Store or whenever the
OS itself receives an upgrade.
Say from the O release
to the P release,
it will clear the contents
of that directory.
So that's a summary
of internal storage.
Next, the other broad
category of locations
is external storage, and when
we think of external storage,
it's more of a shared area.
And it's unprotected
and the reason I just
mentioned that is data that
you store in that location,
you may write it there.
But other applications can
request the storage permission
on Android, and they
may write that data
or modify it without
you knowing about it.
And so it's something
we definitely
discourage storing sensitive
contents in that location.
If you do need to
store data out there,
consider finding a
way to prove to verify
the integrity of that data
if you need to trust it.
The directories here, files are
similar to internal storage,
cached are the same way.
External media
dirs, that you save
in there will be scanned by
media stored on the device.
So it's a good place to
store photos or videos
that you want to be included in
the user's Gallery application
to be scanned and
included there.
GetObbDirs, Obb stands
for Opaque binary blobs,
and these are large
files typically used
for game developers that are
delivered through Google Play.
Data that you store
in those locations,
they're counted
towards your app's code
size instead of its data size.
So so far, we've talked about
broadly internal storage
and external storage, and these
are all great places for you
to store data that
belongs to your app.
But you might find
yourself creating
data that belongs to the user,
that the user may want to store
in a different location.
And that's a great place to use
the storage Access Framework,
and there's two intents
that work great there--
Intent.ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT
and CREATE_DOCUMENT.
These have been around in
the platform since the KitKat
release, and you
can think of them
as an open and a save
dialog box for the user.
It really offers a
great experience,
because the user has control
over exactly where those files
are stored on the device.
It gives them the freedom to
choose any of those locations.
It also opens the door for
cloud storage providers.
You don't have to
integrate a cloud provider
SDK into your application.
You just simply
launch the intent,
and the user can
select where they
want that file to be stored.
There's some great talks that
have dug into this elsewhere,
so I'd encourage you to
search around online.
There's some great content
that digs more in depth.
So we talked about
some basic locations.
Let's do a deep dive on two
specific advanced locations
today.
One that we'll dig
into is Direct Boot,
and the second we'll
dig into is Cache Data.
So first, Direct Boot,
which you may not
have encountered before.
And first, it's
worth starting out
like we built the Direct
Boot feature in the Android N
release to solve an
important problem.
Before the N release, when we
encrypted an Android device,
and if the user
rebooted that device,
no apps could run
until after the user
had entered their credentials--
a pin, pattern, or password.
So what we did in
the N releases,
we created two storage areas
that they're still encrypted,
but they're encrypted
with two different keys.
And we call these areas
the device protected area
and the credential
protected area.
The device protected
area becomes
available by virtue of
the device proving that it
hasn't been tampered with.
So when the device
boots up, there
is dm-verity verifies
that the device
hasn't been tampered with.
By virtue of proving
that, it unlocks
that device protected storage.
Then later, when the user enters
that pin, pattern, or password,
the credential protected
storage becomes
available for
applications to use.
If you haven't encountered
these APIs before,
rest assured that all of your
data by default as an app
developer is always stored
in credential protected area.
But if you find a
place where you'd
like to run before the user
has unlocked their device,
that's where it might
be useful to store
small bits of information out
in that device protected area,
so that your app can be useful
while the device is locked.
So then you might
ask the question,
how do you gain access
to that storage area?
The credential protected
area, as I mentioned,
context.getFilesDir offers
that credential protected area.
There's a method on context,
and you can see it down here
at the bottom of
the screen, create
DeviceProtectedStorageContext.
It's a little bit of a mouthful.
What it does is it returns
another different context where
the file APIs, referring to
internal storage on that return
to context, point at the
device protected storage.
So let's take a look at some
code examples of how you might
integrate with those APIs.
One of the first things
you'll need to do
is if you want to
become Direct Boot aware
is to think about what data
you want to keep on credential
protected storage or migrate
out to device protected storage.
So a lot of you will be
writing code like this
to decide during that
initial upgrade step
how you want to migrate
data back and forth.
The first thing
you'll probably do
when starting your
application is ask is the user
currently unlocked?
Has that pin, pattern,
or password been offered?
So the User Manager class
offers, you can check
is the current user unlocked?
Assuming that they
are unlocked, that
means you have access to both
the device and credential
storage.
And here we can see there's
two move methods that
are offered as helpers.
You can move shared preferences
between two locations,
and you can also move
databases back and forth.
The reason we provide these
helper methods is oftentimes
shared preferences or
databases can actually
be made up of multiple files
on disk, and some of that data
may also be cached in memory.
So by calling these
helper methods
to move that data
around, we ensure
that all the data gets moved and
that any in-memory caches are
invalidated along the way.
When you think about data that
you would want to migrate,
one thing we say is
only move the data
you think you need to
provide that user experience
while the device is locked.
So things like if you're
building an alarm lock app,
you'd probably move the
user's next alarm time out
into that device
protected area to make
sure the alarm clock would go
off if the user's device is
currently locked.
Another strategy
that we've seen used,
if you have auth tokens
to talk to a server,
we've actually
recommended people
create a second type of auth
token for your cloud server.
One, auth token is a full,
rich, full-access token,
which you'd probably use today.
We'd recommend keeping that in
the credential protected area
and creating a second much more
limited in-scope auth token
and only storing that limited
in-scope auth token out
in the device protected area.
Maybe that auth token, when it
talks to your server back end,
is only able to return the
fact that the user has three
unread messages, and maybe
it can't do any operations
beyond that.
So it helps you
deliver the experience
of getting the
user's attention when
you need to but without
being able to access
any of the additional richer
information in your cloud.
OK, so we've talked
if it's unlocked,
we can migrate data
back and forth.
The else clause here, we'd
recommend that you register.
There's a runtime
broadcast that's sent,
an action user
unlocked, and that
would allow you to then run
code when the user enters
that pin, pattern, or password.
The middle code snippet
here, those move methods,
they work both directions.
So if you accidentally
move some data out
into the device
protected area, you
can also move it right back
into the credential area.
And another tidbit,
another API that
might be useful at the
bottom of the screen
there, if you're ever wondering
if a particular file is going
to be encrypted at rest
by the operating system,
you can quickly check
for that as well.
There's a StorageManager
isEncrypted API,
and that can be useful
if you're trying
to decide if you want to
roll your own encryption
or rely on the encryption at
rest that the OS provides.
All right, so a second deep
dive area that we'll dig into
is cached data on the
OS, and this is typically
data that you can regenerate
or redownload later on,
if it happens to be deleted.
And I mentioned earlier that
this is a two way street.
The OS won't count
the data that you
use in that area against your
app, but at the same time,
we reserve the
right to go in there
and delete some of that
data if the user needs
the disk space for something
else that they're doing.
And something that we
improved in the O release
is we rewrote the
algorithms used internally.
One of the biggest questions we
got from you, from developers,
was how much cache space
is appropriate to use?
Can I use 500 meg?
Is that too much?
Is 50 meg too much?
So now we offer
explicit guidance.
There's an API on
Storage Manager
to figure out a cache
quota for your application,
a reasonable amount that
the device thinks is
reasonable for your app to use.
And the nice thing is the OS
adjusts that value over time.
So if the user spends a lot
of time in your application,
we're going to
increase that number
to give you more cache
space to work with,
so that you can offer a better
user experience to your users.
Another thing that we
did in the O release,
we rewrote the
internal implementation
of how that data is cleared.
Before the O release,
we would literally
list all of the cache
files on the OS,
sort them by modified time,
and delete the oldest files.
And you can imagine
that there were
ways you could gamify
that system by setting
your modified time out
to like the year 2038.
So we fixed that, and so now
in O and future releases,
the OS will delete data
from apps that are most
over their quota first.
So what this means, if your app
stays right around the cache
quota that the OS
has recommended,
you can be pretty confident
that your data will be there
and will remain available,
even as the user
starts filling up their disk.
So let's look again
at some code snippets,
like how do we use
this in practice?
So again going to
Storage Manager,
if you're integrating
with a common class,
say like Disk LRU
cache, it's pretty easy
to connect the two
things together.
You can ask the US for that
recommended cache quota bytes
and plug it straight
into the disk
color you cache to help it
trim how much size it's using.
If you have multiple types
of caches, it's up to you
to decide how you want
to fractionally account
or distribute that cache amongst
here, the inside, internals
of your app.
The second code snippet
there, if you're
rolling some of your own
caching, I'd point out
there's a method called
getCacheSizeBytes.
This is a fast way to ask the
question, how much cache space
your app is currently using.
It's an optimized call that
will turn very quickly,
and it's faster than
you having to go iterate
over your own disk usage
to try to figure out
how much space you're using.
Another feature that we
added in the O release which
is covered at the bottom
half of this slide
is the ability to
have cache behaviors,
and we heard this
from developers
that it can be useful.
You may download multiple
files that really should be
treated as a unit or a group.
One concrete example
is downloading
say a movie file and a subtitles
file that goes along with it.
If you store both of those
in the cache directory,
if one of them gets
deleted, the other file
isn't really useful
and valuable.
So the cache behavior offers
you a way to indicate,
to tell us is the operating
system, that if we need disk
space, we should delete both of
those things at the same time.
All right, so we
talked about some
of the common storage locations.
Let's switch gears and talk
about how we can work together,
both the OS helping
you as developers.
And one of the biggest things
that we offered in the O
release is the ability
to help you get the disk
space that you need.
Before the O release, if you
wanted to do a large download,
let's say one gigabyte in size.
And if you'd looked just
at the free disk space,
you may only see 500
megabytes were free,
and it may look like that
download was impossible.
But there's a new API
in the O release, where
the OS will offer to go and
delete cache files belonging
to other applications
to help free up the disk
space for that operation to
succeed for your application.
If there still isn't
enough disk space,
there's new intents
that you can launch
to help get the user involved,
to help them pick items
and different things that
they can do to help free
up that disk space.
So how do we use this API?
Here's a snapshot of this.
The very top of the slide, this
is maybe the way that you've
been writing code today.
You'll just do a
pretty simple check.
You have a download size
you're comparing it against.
Java.io.File.getUsableSpace
how much space is there?
That's the operation that
may look like it wouldn't
be possible to succeed.
But if you convert your code
to using the rest with a code
snippet on this slide, if
you call the StorageManager.g
etAllocatableBytes API,
that will return not just
the free space, it
will also include space
that the OS is
willing to go free up
on your behalf from other
applications' cache data.
So in this case, it may look
like if we have enough space
inside of that if block, we can
actually open that file output
stream.
And now there's an API
call allocate bytes,
and what this will do
is it will go actually
claim that disk space,
free application.
Deep underneath, it'll
use the F allocate
system call to ensure
that those blocks belong
to your application, and that
you do have the space that's
guaranteed to belong to you.
So that could be a
useful API to use.
And the else block
here, if there still
wasn't enough space, we now
offer some great intents
for you to ask the user
for help to come along
and free up information,
free up the disk space.
Sharing content, we've covered
this a little bit before.
How can we work together there?
Please always use
content URIs when you're
sharing between applications.
Never use file
URIs, and the reason
is that receiving
application, they
may not have the permissions
that they need to directly
access the files on disk.
If you use content
URIs, the OS can
manage the dynamic permissions
to give the receiving
app, to make sure that
they can open the content.
If you find yourself
in this position,
File Provider in
the support library
is a great way to
convert between the two
with a single line of code
every place to convert from file
to content.
And over the years, because
this is an important thing
to pay attention to, we
built strict mode APIs
to help you track down to
detect these places in your app.
You can detect places where you
might be accidentally sharing
file URIs, and now, in
a more recent release,
you can also detect places where
you're sharing a content URI,
and you might be forgetting
the flag_grant_read
or the flag_grant_write to
go along with that intent.
So those can be two APIs
that are helpful to look at.
Native code is another
area to think about.
We'd strongly recommend that
you look at opening files up
in higher level managed
code, up in Java or Kotlin,
and passing down the
already open file
descriptor, the integer,
down into native code.
And the reason for that is
opening in a managed code
gives the OS the opportunity to
notice and inspect and correct
things.
In particular, it can look
for strict mode violations.
If you open a
managed code, you may
notice that the thread that
you're currently running on
is important to the
user, may block or cause
jank in your app,
and we're going
to start using this more
in future Android releases.
So this is why we want
to strongly encourage,
open the file in Java or
the higher level language,
pass the integer
down to native code.
Don't pass the file path
itself across the JNI boundary.
And a quick code snippet
of what that looks
like, you can pretty quickly do
this with ParcelFileDescriptor.
You can open a particular
file on disk, maybe
for read/write in
this case, and there's
a method called detachfd that
will return that integer.
It's just an int
that is ready for you
to pass across a JNI
boundary as a jint.
So that's the recommended
design going forward.
Another note that might be
at a trick or a tip that
could be useful.
If you find yourself
just jumping across JNI
to do a handful of
system calls, you
might go look at
Android.system.OS.
There are several dozen
POSIX syscalls ready
for you to use up in Java today.
We only added that a
couple of releases ago.
So you may be able
to find that you
can do those handful of
syscalls purely in Java,
and you may be able to get rid
of the JNI and the native code
in your application.
So take a look at that.
And finally, working
with media, we'd
really recommend that you
use Media Store if you're
looking to find the photos
or videos that the user has
on their device.
And you might be
tempted to go and build
your own index of
whatever media you find,
but that can be pretty
wasteful, both of CPU
and battery for the user.
And another note
is we're actively
working on improving Media Store
and really adding functionality
there, so stay tuned over
the next couple releases.
Another note is open files,
open the content of that media,
through Content Resolver.
You may have noticed
that there are columns
across the operating system
called underscore data
and they return a
raw file system path.
Over time, you may have
noticed that a handful of those
underscore data columns
have been deprecated
in previous releases,
and just to expect
that's going to continue.
So you'll notice more of
those underscore data columns
becoming deprecated over time.
We really want to encourage
people to move towards content
URIs as a best practice.
So yeah, thank
you for your time,
being able to dig into some
of the nitty gritty areas
of storage, and I'll be
available in the Q&A section
afterwards, if you
have questions for me.
Thanks for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]